[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks a happy
thursday to all of you it's your
favorite non-andre yang co-host zach
grauman with the one and only carly
riley so what am i if you're the
favorite non-andrew yang co-host
i was it was plural carl that was clever
welcome back folks on today's episode
here's what we're doing we are going to
dive in
on
this texas abortion law that everyone
seems to be talking about is
pretty horrifying even if you
ever everybody is talking about it
except republicans this is the
fascinating thing is that which means
republicans probably horrified by it as
well correct and then
uh at least your average republican and
uh we want to dive into this ivermectin
drug that joe rogan used to quote
unquote carry himself from kovid and i
wanna we gotta debunk a lot of that
because the media is going nuts and you
know
carly that's our favorite time when the
media is going nuts um wait we should
start though i think
with uh the scandal of the week not
actually but uh you tweeted something
over vacation
and
i think very flippantly
or like just
you know i was sitting at a cafe
at like it was vacation so i got to wake
up late and i woke up and i went and got
a coffee and sit by myself having my
like chocolate croissant whatever they
had at the bakery it was great and i
tweeted something i thought was pretty
harmless i tweeted
normalize having friends with different
political views than you do to be fair
why did you think that was gonna be
harmless
because i think
who the heck has friends that that agree
with everything they believe in i don't
think that that shouldn't i have friends
that disagree on everything people i
love um people who are
people who are liberal people who are a
little more conservative but like i have
friends that disagree and oh my god is
your privilege speaking zachary
is it
well i it is a privilege to have friends
that
are outside of yours i'm going to
provide the lefty i don't know i'm going
to provide the lefty lefty perspective
on this but not yet let's first finish
telling the story so you tweet this and
then a bunch of people were mad
a whole bunch of people were
oh should we normalize being friends
with nazis zach and that was fun oh yeah
i was asked um because i like you know
of course saw some of the replies and so
then i made the point about the fact i
was like you realize like
you know ruth bader ginsburg who is
probably the hero or the purported hero
of many people on the thread you know
she's somebody hugely admire was very
good friends with antonin scalia so then
i had people messaging me being like oh
like how many hamas friends do you have
carly like where are all your mom's
friends so this was this was i think the
fundamental uh
first fundamental disconnect was you
meant like
within your friends that really
like you could have
you could have you know i have friends
who are much further left than i am
right or like you could even be within a
particular party like it you're not even
talking about
and then everybody else interpreted it
like at the most extreme level of course
because it's twitter and that let me say
a couple things and then i'd love uh
yeah i want you to teach me um we talked
a little bit about this but the the
farther left side i guess is here's what
i'd like to say yes there are a couple
lines that should not be crossed in
friendships and you know someone who has
hate in their heart is someone i do not
want to be friends with right so
i can't believe i'm clarifying this no
i'm not friends with nazis what the
um
that's not what that tweet meant um
but i want
to say this for everybody who or anybody
that it possibly bothered
that 74 million people voted republican
in the last election 74 million people
voted for donald trump so if you think
that 74 million of those people that all
74 million are morally bankrupt i hate
to say this you are the problem
and that doesn't mean that there's
plenty of morally banker people that are
vote republican there's plenty of
morally banker people that vote
libertarian and democrat and everywhere
but
there is a large chunk of them that are
regular human beings that disagree with
you they're not [ __ ] they don't
believe in suffering they just have a
different view they live in a bubble
there's a million reasons they could be
voting for different political views and
it i believe you should have friends on
both sides of the aisle because if you
don't they don't have anyone pulling
them the other way so yeah well and okay
on the i'm going to give the more lefty
perspective on this in a second i think
tell me why i'm wrong on the pulling
people the other way
that sort of
why i end up fully landing with you zack
is i'm like so what are you suggesting
then if you disagree with the idea if
you say no we absolutely can't have
friends who are on the other sides of
the aisle then lester's have the civil
war now right like then let's just
succeed like what i i don't we'll never
agree then we hate each other then how
do we
and the personal example i'll give is is
my mom and hopefully all my relatives
aren't listening but like my mom has a
cousin who's a uh was like a big trump
supporter or
and
through like a number of dialogues
she actually started to see like oh like
she was in a bubble and started to see
that because my mom was willing to
engage with her and have conversations
with her dialogues with her and i have a
ton of friends that lean right whatever
voted republican and because of my
involvement with andrew yang
voted left this time i voted for biden i
just from a practical perspective i
approach it like it's so critical to be
able to pull people
uh
further left in my case right like
that's what i want to do with people who
are on the other side of the aisle from
me and that requires trust and a certain
amount of friendship etcetera okay yeah
on on
the left side of this right i just want
to give some credit to this i do
understand that in their head right
they're like okay
privileged white people who are not
existently threatened by policies like
there's there's no policy that the
government can implement tomorrow
in any sort of realistic world that's
going to like destroy our lives
however if you are somebody who is poor
if you are you know in certain
marginalized communities so take this
you know think of texas and this
abortion ban that we're going to talk
about right like there are women who are
now
specifically for poor women who are
going to be forced into scenarios where
they
are living a life of poverty
that they did not get to choose for
themselves that they did not want
because of a mistake call it quote
unquote right that that rich women get
to make all the time which is oops i
had sex with somebody and maybe i was
drunk and so i didn't use protection or
whatever and now i'm in this situation
um and so when you and and that's sort
of an existential threat to
that person's life right and so
the left feels like
no how could i be friends with or like
how can i find a middle ground with
somebody who thinks so little of my life
because i'm poor or because i'm black or
because i'm a woman or whatever like
i can't justify that and they see that
as very synonymous with being a
supporter of trump because like how
could you overlook
his treatment of women
the things he said about black people
muslim people how can you overlook all
that that shows a certain moral
bankruptcy that i can't surround myself
with
right that's left perspective
and that makes a lot of sense i think
those arguments frankly give more credit
to people that they are paying that much
attention i think they're like they're
not following
trump's tweet of the day and all that
they they've lost trust in the media
like many folks i'm not saying i'm not
giving him a pass um but i think
the left tends to follow donald trump's
every move almost even more than the
right does in a strange way um
so no that's actually totally true so
for example the
person the kind of friend of my mom's
who was a trump supporter who she
kind of pulled left
more so
like genuinely thought that
didn't think he had ever actually gone
bankrupt she thought that was all a lie
like people have gotten to the point
where they think all of these negative
things that are said about trump are
just lies no again it's like okay we'll
listen to what he's what is literally
coming out of his mouth but um
there's a bubble factor and people lost
trust so like i think the i do think
that far left perspective on it is a
very self-absorbed one i think it's
saying that
like with the and we'll get into this a
little bit right with the with the
abortion example right like
the people who are opposed to abortion
see it as murder
and they are not focused on hey i'm
trying to impoverish this woman right
like that's not the scope and the angle
that they're looking at
at all
um and i i do happen to be a believer
like you have to meet people where they
are not where you think they should be
and so to i do think it's very
self-absorbed to a certain extent to say
like
you know
this person is just
i you know i i think there's a certain
self-absorption to that mentality yeah i
think so look
we'll talk about this texas bill is
important but um
i would say this like this stuff like
people hating on me on twitter
just for what it's worth like it does
not bother me like par for the course
has been happening but what does bother
me is like from it bothers me from a
state of the world standpoint or at
least the state of twitter was like oh
oh [ __ ] we've just collectively lost our
mind um and because that's a very
harmless statement uh
like in the grand scheme of things but
in certain bubbles it's a very offensive
statement and
so uh sorry twitter uh it will not be
the last time i piss you off and uh
certainly not first so here we go um
but i i do think we just all need to
pick our heads up and love each other
and i thought that was a loving tweet
like have friends on the other side of
the aisle it's okay to disagree with
certain people and i understand that
i've come from and i'm sorry i can't be
all things all people um i try not be an
[ __ ] i really do
[Music]
real talk how is your mental health if
it's like mine probably not that great
i'm losing my mind postcovid getting a
little better and the reason i'm getting
better is because of our sponsor
betterhelp which is
amazing secure
and well frankly fairly priced
counseling done securely online so you
can start communication and get paired
with
a licensed professional
on a safe private online environment
that's super convenient within 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online you can talk to
your counselor anytime you get timely
and thoughtful responses i love my
counselor it's freaking awesome and you
can get advice on depression or anger or
stress or family complex whatever you're
going through
better help is freaking awesome and it's
confidential convenient professional
affordable all the things you need done
conveniently online so i want you to
start living a happier life today and as
a listener you're going to get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com yang so join over 1
million people
taking charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp
help.com
yang
[Music]
okay
this text is abortion law yeah
i saw let me say this carl i saw all the
hype um so this laws is a
horrendous in a lot of levels but i saw
the hype and i was like okay
this seems bad but is the right
overblowing things the leftover blowing
things right and then i read
i didn't read the law that's not fair
but i started reading the breakdowns
from from all sorts all sides and the
right-wing outlines aren't really
covering it so it's a lot of but as many
neutral sites i could
and it's pretty rough um
and and it it seems
wrong outside of the abortion
conversation it seems
like something we wouldn't do on any
issue
it is something that should frankly
horrify both sides of the aisle because
you want to talk about creating
a
illiberal state
and creating like an authoritarian
crazy
like
overreach
it's it it checks all these boxes beyond
even the laws about abortion so do you
want to give an overview here and then
i'll break down the law at least from
like i'm not claiming to be an expert um
but i will give it for for those of you
who have just probably seen the hype
like that's dark but maybe you haven't
gotten involved this is kind of where
you're at um now this so basically there
was a new abortion law in texas that
bans abortions after six weeks and
the supreme court it passed a while ago
um and other states have passed it as
well on their own versions but they
haven't really been upheld the courts
are fighting them but the supreme court
upheld it i believe was five to four
um
upheld this law
so this law is pretty nuts so it allows
so basically
it is the reason it's so complicated is
because it's not the state
regulating and banning abortions it's
allowing private citizens to sue
abortion providers which is a very loose
term so it allows private citizens to
sue abortion providers and anyone else
who helps obtain helps a woman obtain an
abortion and that's critical not anyone
else i mean if you but anyone else that
could be your friends
if you give money to somebody even if
you don't know that money is being used
for an abortion if it gets used for an
abortion you can be sued yeah and you
can do it all over the state so it's
essentially meant to financially and
painfully harass all abortion providers
so that can be women or anyone who gives
a woman a ride to a clinic or provides
financial assistance assistance to
obtain an abortion
um
and if you're a private citizen who
brings this suit you actually don't need
to show any connections to those you're
suing if you sue and you win you get a
ten thousand dollar prize and your legal
fees covered and they have a
whistleblowing website
that you can literally just flag so um i
mean this kind of like people the le
this is where i totally agree with the
left and they've been saying you're
putting a bounty on like fellow citizens
and it's it's totally true like this is
just a bounty out there for people to
collect
and
yes it is so sick and i do think this is
why
republicans aren't advertising it more
because that kind of like
government-sanctioned government-enabled
law-enforced like
citizen nanny state just feels like it
would be everything they don't want when
you're talking about like individual
freedoms get out of my yard get out of
my hair
it's um the other thing that i think is
is so horrific about this is it doesn't
have carve outs in the law for cases of
rape or incest so if you are raped if
you were raped by your father
it is still
completely illegal for you to still get
the uber driver get sued for taking you
to planned parenthood now
what's crazy is that we don't do this
for actual murder
because like yes we report people who
you know commit a nasty crime like
murder but we don't if an uber driver
drives a person who then goes and
commits a murder we don't get to sue the
uber driver right right you could go
down if it's done in a restaurant
like that restaurant doesn't get sued
you go to that list um obviously they're
different but it's like the fundamentals
of this are
to me ridiculous and the reason it's so
complicated is because it's not state
banning it's private citizens because
you can't technically ban it you can't
technically put somebody in prison for
having an abortion so you just need to
cut off all access
and it's so that the estimations are
wild but it's around 80 to 85 percent of
women who would want an abortion or seek
an abortion
would be prevented from getting one
given this um the other thing is the six
weeks piece is that
six weeks
i mean
mostly you basically don't even know
you're right at that point right yeah um
and so you wouldn't know you don't know
until four weeks so you basically have a
two-week window to
take a pregnancy test and make a
decision and then get to a clinic like
that's
you know it's it's rough so
um
that is the law um carly i'm very
interested in your thoughts um i have
some but i also agree with
andrew on the presidential trail you
should say um
he thinks men should leave the room when
it comes to talking about women's rights
and abortion admission sec women's
sexual health rights and on um on one
hand i very much agree with that why
should men be having any say but then i
agree with you we've talked about this
before like that's also a cop-out for
men to be like oh i don't know i gotta
let you you know uh and then it lets
shittier men like
have the loudest voice in the room so i
do think it's important for guys like me
to say something um
in defense or against this law which i'm
doing but i i want to hear from you
carly um
i mean i i i i hate it i absolutely hate
it i think
um one of the things that i've thought
about as this has
all come about is
i remember a number of years ago you
know texas was trying to pass some law
that was very restrictive about
abortions they've you know they've tried
many iterations of this
and the leading lawmaker in texas
who was
writing
you know whose team had like crafted the
language for this legislation in texas
did not know that
you know the majority of abortions at
this point are
are a pill right like for for people to
understand you know when women get
abortions the majority of them take a
pill and
that handles it this person thought that
basically he thought all abortions were
um like late term abortions right where
you had to like actually go in and
and like
you know i i don't i don't want to get
too graphic i guess here but like he had
a very very fundamental misunderstanding
about how abortions even happen and it
just makes me so angry that you have
these people pushing legislations and
they have no freaking idea what they're
actually talking about um i i'm really
i'm in support of
there was some actress recently who came
out said i turned on a movie role that i
liked because it was shooting in texas i
think the city of portland said they
like won't engage in any trade or like
economic back and forth with texas i
support all of this like i am fully
happy to cut texas off for this i think
it's it's really really harmful and
that's sort of how pro-choice i am
now with all of that said
i am going to probably wade into some
mild controversy here because i also
happen to think
that the way
we as democrats
kind of slogan and message around
abortion
is a little irritating uh and
specifically the slogan like my body my
choice this whole notion of like why do
you get to control my body
we're signaling to the base well there
but we are not in any way trying to
engage with republicans when we use that
slogan and i'll i'll explain why and
i'll give a better better than one
better way to talk to conservatives
about abortions okay
there is a whole wing of people who are
pro-life
who don't realize that their underlying
motivation is totally sexism and trying
to control women i believe that very
thoroughly if you look at the history of
roe v wade in this country for example
it was not that controversial when it
passed and then you had religious groups
who started to like mobilize people
around this for electoral reasons blah
blah blah we won't get into that whole
history what i want to say now is at
this point in this day and age there are
many people who genuinely believe that
abortion is murder
and
like
when do we become human beings right
like when does this become when does it
not right and so there's like a certain
i don't agree with it right but there's
a certain logic
someone would say hey the
viability outside the womb was at one
point when roe v wade was passed but now
viability outside the womb is is earlier
than that and it's just getting earlier
and earlier and we may reach a point
where you're viable outside the womb
at six weeks right so if that was the
previous test for what made an abortion
okay or not like it it's tricky
so i think saying my body my choice the
fact that i have autonomy over my body
does not give me the right to murder
someone correct so there's always been a
disconnect for me in using that slogan
on the left to try and counter the right
who is saying essentially this is murder
we should ban murder
but here's so here's what i think we
need to do right we need to
get republicans to acknowledge and to
have to come to terms with the fact
that this is not cut and dry like this
is not
clearly murder there's
there's something more complicated here
so there's a thought experiment that i
heard that i think is really powerful
which is
okay you are in a fertility clinic that
is burning down and in one corner you
have
a thousand fertilized embryos and in the
other corner you have a two-year-old
child
what do you save you can only save one
and for me and i have to imagine for
most people the obvious instinct is
you're going to save the two-year-old
child
because there is clearly a difference
between a human being out in the world
and
a cluster of cells right or or
a not born an unborn being
and i i think any any honest republican
would actually have to grapple with that
question and it starts to raise that
point that
this is not clear-cut this is not
clearly murder and um
i just think that's a more interesting
way to start a dialogue with a
conservative than trying to say like my
body my choice which feels like a um
honestly just a
a way to signal to the base and great
and fine but it doesn't
really cut to the heart of it for me
here's the other one um
here's how to say
there's a difference between what
what one individual believes morally
than what is moral or right from a
policy perspective and i think
we often
slash almost always conflate the two and
it's really important to think about
both i think a good example is marijuana
for for me i like pot but i don't think
it's great if people are high all the
time whether it's immoral or not like i
don't know i think if you're a pothead
and you're smoking all day long it lead
to laziness absent fathers bad parents
like people driving machines and they
shouldn't be that high like i don't
think
people smoking weed all day is a good
thing i don't think people speaking
smoking weed inju i am moral
like 80s dad like just saying no to
drugs they're lazy and
you know like no but
like if we're honest though like does it
make you lazier of course it does like
anyone who smokes weed is like yeah i
mean there's certain people yeah there's
some people who actually i think get
like bursts i know people who get bursts
of productivity actually when they smoke
generally the exception i understand
your right broader point let's take it
like most people who smoke weed get a
little higher it's not a bad thing i'm
not judging people it's not like
the most productive drug generally
speaking right um
do cocaine instead kids sure yeah but my
point is like i don't i don't morally
love
people getting high all the time i don't
think that's like what a great man of
integrity or great father should be
doing um
i'm not judging this is my personal
moral opinion
however
in practice trying to take my morals and
putting them into law is a disaster and
we've lived it people still get
marijuana regardless so that's not
working it creates a black market which
increases crime and deceit and waste
government resources to stop the trade
of marijuana on the street when we could
just be taxing and actually getting
revenue
and we apparently can't enforce
marijuana like distribution or use
without being freaking racist so all
ambition all all in the prohibition of
pot which may be something morally
people could be against
it practically is a complete mess and i
think abortion is very very similar um
where
one may think that
abortion is morally wrong and there are
plenty of people who don't think it's a
good thing for us to be celebrating
abortions um however from a policy
standpoint
banning abortion becomes a disaster you
don't abandon abortions you actually ban
safe abortions if anyone's seen cider
house rules it's very well done and very
obvious how this works um
and frankly you start you just
economically hurt some of your least
fortunate in the world right and you
don't end up banning abortions for rich
women you you ban abortions poor women
right and
i mean there was an interesting
freakonomex made a point the book for
economics made a point that became
somewhat famous which is that they
tracked
the passage of roe v wade and the
decline of crime in major cities and
they saw it basically tracked perfectly
that you started to have a decline in
crime in cities right when the the kids
that weren't born that would have been
coming of age
to be involved in crime at that like
weren't um now people have criticized
that but but i i do think
it makes sense right that when you give
women the choice to family plan and to
um
have more autonomy over their lives and
the direction of it and their finances i
mean powerful positive things happen
i think to close on this i'll say i'll
say one note which was a stat that i i
read years ago that has stuck with me
which is this is a we're talking
globally now but no country has lifted
themselves out of poverty in the last 50
years without expanding access to birth
control and that's obviously a relevant
part of this conversation because it
just goes to say that when you empower
women
to make their own choices around family
planning remarkable things happen like
women being able to
control their fates in that way and
control their finances in that way is
amazing and we are stripping that away
so i'm really horrified
yeah
um and this is one of the so look
we like to make this podcast of action
in this case there's little you i mean
there's a lot of people fighting back
especially if you live in those states
but to us
i i think one of the best weapons we can
give those who are pro-choice here is
the ability to have the moral
conversation with
those on the other side of this issue um
and so that is either the moral policy
argument i was just making or the one
you were making is that in a burning
building would you save a tower of
embryos or a small child most of us
would save that small the vast majority
would save that small child
[Applause]
[Music]
i know you guys were worried you were
like when are they gonna do another
tushy ad
and today is that day
because we haven't done a tushy yet in a
long time tushy for those you don't know
is the modern bidet company instead of
using toilet paper which is more
expensive and a little less comfortable
and not as good for the environment
tushy
is what they do in europe they use
bidets and they spray water on you and
it's freaking awesome so
the tushy models these bidets especially
the new ones they just click to your
toilet there's basic installation it's
so simple
and it saves you money on toilet paper
and it's more enjoyable so
tushy is the modern bidet right now so
just poop wash and pat dry and it is
awesome and it's better for the
environment so the tushy bidet features
a number of things it washes you with
water so better clean than toilet paper
it's less irritating more soothing for
you it's easy to install it attaches the
toilet in under 10 minutes no
electricity or plumbing required using a
tushy bidet reduces your toilet paper
use by 80 percent saving you money it's
eco-friendly and it's stylish and you
could be like that cool guy or gal that
has a bidet in their home so check it
out guys start washing with tushy bidet
for a better clean so go to
hellotushy.com
and get 10 off plus free shipping so you
get 10 off this thing and save a bunch
of money on toilet paper and be cooler
and be happier and let's call it more
content with your going experience so 10
off and free shipping this is a special
offer for just our yang speaks listeners
at hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off after you buy install
your tushy show it off tag us and tag
them at
hellotushy on instagram so
hellotushy.com
yang get 10 off free shipping right now
[Music]
[Applause]
but speaking of i guess the right or
left freaking out
let's talk about joe rogan and
ivermectin because
this was wild um
and carly and i will start here carly
and i are not doctors but i have been i
have
two of my really best friends one in
particular is like my best friend uh is
a like a very successful doctor at texas
children's in houston in texas uh
so he sees all sorts of all this so he's
been my go-to but i've been texting my
doctor friends to get some insights on
this but let me give you some context
and then carl you could probably add
more too so um on august 28th on
saturday august 20th joe rogan the one
and only joe rogan experience he posted
on instagram that he had covet
it seemed like you got it maybe like
i think he posted it i think on monday
but he got it on saturday on august 20th
um
and
eventually he said he felt good by
wednesday september 1st a few days after
and he talked about the
just like onslaught of meds and vitamins
he threw himself with and that included
a lot of things i think people should do
when they're sick like vitamin drips if
they can afford it and things like that
but he talked about monoclonal
antibodies deca zpac he took prednisone
and he took he mentioned something
literally in passing called
ivermectin
and
by
friday september 3rd he had tested
negative so basically in like five or
six days i wanna like i'm like
suppressing a laughter all this because
i'm just like god our world has gotten
so crazy
yeah oh like a
well
finished i mean he's some super he's a
super rich celebrity right he just like
took a bunch of [ __ ] and suddenly messed
himself up with drugs uh my twitter feed
was like inundated with commentary on
joe rogan's choice of ivy mechden
anyways continue and i don't think i
wanna be fair to joe i don't think he
was like guys take ivermectin but the
press was like definitely see though joe
rogan on his podcast like touting ivor
beckton or
bringing a gaston who was touting
ivermectin he's definitely you know
that's that's the the currency he trades
and is definitely like
asking questions of people who have like
dubious things
i know people [ __ ] hate him i don't
he's on record saying that young healthy
people should not get the vaccine right
right right right um obviously
which we disagree with so i wanna let's
start with this to be very very clear
y'all
ivermectin what is it it's an
anti-parasitic drug
it did win the nobel peace prize in 2015
for its success in combining river
blindness and other tropical maladies
vets
veterinarians use it to prevent
heartworm and parasitic infections in
some animals and
it is used for quote-unquote doctor
friend resistant life infections and
drug-resistant scabies
in children um and and the bigger point
and i think you pointed this out to me
zach is there had been
i guess trials done in egypt or
something
at some point during this whole covet
situation
that suggested uh ivermectin actually
might be quite powerful in countering
kovid and all of those studies have
since been retracted or debunked by uh
legitimate doctors so let's be clear
don't take ivermectin we gotta hammer
that don't take this [ __ ] um there is no
compelling evidence that it does
anything no evidence that it works there
is no peer-reviewed studies
that have said this works and there is a
lot of downside way more downside than
we talked about with the vaccine like
it's not close and i will say people
like brett weinstein and some of these
folks who have become i would say very
conspiratorial in in sort of
the covet era but people who has
historically said things that i think
are smart he was one of these guys
really pushing the ivermectin thing he's
also now an anti-vaxxer um but i think
when he was pushing it if i'm not
mistaken it was back before sort of
these uh
so indecisive
trials had been debunked this is where
we all got confused so in december 2020
pierre cory who was a critical care
physician who used to work for the
university of wisconsin health
university uh university hospital um
testified before the u.s senate like
homeland security and government affairs
committee
saying
that this thing was awesome i think the
direct quote was a miracle drug he said
it was great um
and there were a bunch of studies there
was one done in egypt um
massive study like 2000 patients and
found that it was great um but the study
which got a lot of positive press and
then the study got ripped apart um it
started
it wasn't a double blind study they
compared people who took ivermectin
versus hydroxychloroquine which is
something donald trump talked about
which also is terrible for them the fish
tank cleaner but some med student was
like looked into this and was like you
got like a sign this and then like is
part of this like like getting his bed
degree it was like yo
uh this is [ __ ] and like this was
plagiarized like it's horrible um the
author and he's like the list of the
holes they found the study is ridiculous
the authors claim to have done the study
on 18 to 80 year olds but there are at
least three patients in the data set who
are under 18. they can they claim to do
the study between the 8th of june and
the 20 september in 2020 however
most of the patients who died were
admitted to the hospital before the
eighth of june uh and then they had a
bunch of errors in the data that had
like made up dates like
june 31st and things like that like the
study was
nonsense to the point
where it got pulled down there was no
like major research database that that
hosted the site but the one that did i
think was called research square
um
pulled it down they took it down because
like this is a joke so there's now
really literally nothing that suggests
if you're if you're doubting so here's
the deal like world health organization
infectious diseases society america and
the fda are all like don't [ __ ] take
iberomecton but if you don't believe
them if you're like i don't trust
anybody
merc
the [ __ ] pharmaceutical company that
makes the drug
that profits off of ivermectin was like
a formal press release like please for
the love of god do not take it no
scientific basis for this no meaningful
evidence for clinical activity or
efficacy in patients with coven19 and a
concerning lack of safety data in the
majority of study they said all three of
those things yeah for a bit i'm gonna
put the link in our day so
this
conversation is ridiculous uh okay and
the side effects are disgusting i will
say this first came on my radar this
whole joe rogan thing
from glenn greenwald who
has been sort of critical of the media's
coverage of all this because all of this
being true the media it appears did what
they often do which is
just like
way oversimplified and so
the media was just like endlessly
referring this referring to ivermectin
as a horse tranquilizer and like a horse
drug or something and
which it is which it is but it is also
used in humans it's also it's a little
bit unfair or misleading you know it
does that thing which is like it allows
democrats to be like i roll god can you
believe just how stupid these people are
like they're taking horse whatever
tranquilizers
can be prescribed and it feels like the
thing you and i talk about which it
feels counterproductive because when
then you have individuals who maybe lean
a little bit more to the right or who
happen to know that ivermectin is
something that is used to treat human
beings at times for parasites and other
things and they see them only referring
to it as a horse tranquilizer and
they're like well you don't actually you
clearly don't know the full story like
you don't even it's like i'm not gonna
trust anything you say and it becomes
kind of counterproductive now the
counter to that is that
the only over-the-counter version of
ivermectin you can get does appear to be
the one for horses i find this whole
thing like honestly funny and i'm sorry
i know we're gonna be mad because like
people are dying but like this is
[ __ ] hilarious like so the increased
demand for the joints
scrutiny from pharmacists there's been
shortages of the veterinary formulations
of the drug and a spike of calls to
poison control centers because this
stuff's nasty guys
now there was also take iron acting
the vaccine now this is the the second
part of the story though is so you have
glenn greenwald he's mad because he's
like the media keeps calling it's a
horse tranquilizer or whatever the [ __ ]
and it's he's on the right
he's like a libertarian kind of well the
irony is glenn greenwald has always been
like
super lefty like he used to be yeah
i think glenn greenwald is still
incredibly left what he is is he's so
far left that he also sees the lies of
the media right like like the defund
police movement feels like the
mainstream media doesn't give their
views proper coverage like he i don't
know if he's pro-defending the police
but i wouldn't be surprised like he's
he's super super lefty okay to the point
that he he becomes
like friendly with the right in our like
in this talk about the horseshoe you
know the far right and the far left
start to touch at the end okay um
so
uh so anyways and then
he
then the like the kind of like
fiesta rosa sons or whatever like the
like the pinnacle of this whole thing
was
rolling stone did a story claiming that
there were like gunshot victims in
oklahoma
who weren't being treated at a hospital
because there were all these backups at
the hospital due to the number of people
being treated for overdosing on
ivermectin
and rachel maddow retweeted a version of
that story
and it turns out that also is not true
and you had the hospital where these
people were apparently being treated put
out a statement being like no we have
not seen some surge in people taking
ivermectin we we like totally have
capacity like this isn't true so of
course the right latches onto that and
they're like oh like look at these
vultures like claiming fake news all the
time and like rachel maddow has still
has this story tweeted she's never been
trusted with the vaccine
and get this right
that's no that's what's happening this
is why we want to talk about because
it's like you have these
both the right and the left they're just
going nuts all the time and if you're an
average person you're like okay well is
i ever make it bad because i do like joe
rogan i do trust him and he seemed to
use it and get better so maybe it worked
and this really is at the core of it
like i think i was saying this to you
beforehand like even doing research for
this it feels like
it's very hard to trust anybody you read
because it does feel like this is one of
those cases where everyone has an agenda
it feels like the people on
one side
want to prove how unfair the media is so
they want to give undue credit to
ivermectin and then the other cohort is
just like so gleeful at the idea of
getting to like spit on joe rogan that
they just like can't wait to tell you
how how absurd ivermectin is and it's
only used for horses etc and so
it just leaves this like information
vacuum that i know so many of us feel
where we're like i don't even know where
to get the real story
i had to talk to actual doctors like
friends of yours yeah
um to get good info on this and he sent
me a really good article written by a
former commissioner in the fda maybe
ideally it was this person or assistant
commissioner whoever was um but it
ideally was back when we used to trust
institutions when uh
yeah because you were talking about a
study that was put out by like but like
you basically developed it all i believe
um yeah
debunks everything and the point is like
look
i do believe all of this um
[Music]
are
it's a personal like until it's
federally mandated um it's a personal
choice right now like you i want people
to get the vaccine you should you should
do we get a whole episode of this but it
is your choice and joe rogan super rich
super like into health and fitness and
he eats elk and bow hunts and all that
stuff like that's what he does if he
wants to pump himself up with horse
parasite medicine and vitamins and stuff
that's fine and it's also important you
know he's like being administered by top
doctors like this is not he's not so
like home alone just bringing a liar i'm
just going to continue
and i heard this was good like you know
he's got
a whole bunch of stuff going into him
and um
i think
frankly that's fine it's a free country
you knew we want but
all right i'm going to wrap
to do is to
get some more info and so we're trying
to provide that that's all i'm saying
i'm going to wrap this up because we are
recording this much later than we
usually do uh due to a surge of work
that both you and i ended up having
today so it is yeah it is bedtime why we
can't wrap this up yet because today
is bills thing
yes of course it is
oh my god guess what josh allen begins
his mvp campaign and the bill super bowl
run this sunday one o'clock against
pittsburgh steelers in buffalo and guess
what
i will be there and guess who's coming
with me
carly riley she's coming her first time
buffalo i was going to make a snide
comment but the truth is i'm actually
really excited i've been hearing about
buffalo bills tailgates for
truly years at this point uh carly's
doing um
there's this guy named pinto ron that
does fireball shots out of a bowling
ball and carly's taking one it's oh this
is the [ __ ]
volleyball yep that's how you get
covered that's right yeah that is yeah
this is the first one you have to be
back hey give buffalo credit you have to
be vaccinated to get into the tailgate
and the stadium and you have to wear a
mask when you're inside so we'll be
relatively safe um good you love it
doesn't matter it's gonna be 60 000
people going crazy
and bill's bills by a million anyway i
love you all i hope this episode was
pissed everyone off
i feel like you probably did i don't
know so i think everything pisses
everyone off so i'll get you i don't
really care we don't tend to care either
way so we're not important enough to get
canceled for more than like an hour um
we can't get thought we have such a
disagreement about the cancelled thing
which is you use that term so liberally
and to me like
i'm not getting fired and so
like canceling requires like a loss of
income which neither you or i are at
risk of so that's at the moment for now
um we love you guys enjoy your weekend
see you next time
[Music]
you